total feeling coup grand gagnant de la
jam battle comtesse de trappes déjà
vainqueurs lors de la deuxième édition
les total feeling fous ont su conserver
leur titre la battle contest est
organisée par l'association stricte hip
hop elle rassemble une centaine de gênes
pour une compétition de hip hop
d'attendre ou quatorze équipes est
précisément de 8 qui viennent de france
maghreb belgique le sud de la france la
bretagne qui vont s'affronter l'un
contre l'autre pour gagner 400 euros à
la fin et des lots de vêtements de la
marque apple pour rappel une battle de
hip hop c'est un affrontement de dons
entre deux équipes à tour de rôle pour
un seul vainqueur